- Are you interested in
a career in consulting?
Most people that I know that
interview for consulting roles
have one thing that
they are most scared of,
and this is the case interview.
So welcome to another video here
on my channel Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich, I'm a
former McKinsey consultant
and today let me share a
couple of case interview tips.
And specifically we're going to look
onto the three main components
of most case interviews.
First, the qualitative part.
Second, the data reasoning part and third,
the quantitative part.
So surely formats differ from before
but I'd argue that these things are part
of most of these case interview formats
so let's get into it.
The purpose of the case interview
in a consulting interview process
is to test how comfortable
you are with situations
that you will face as a consultant.
So the interviewer will present you
with it a business problem
and then expect you to solve it.
Sometimes in the more unstructured way,
sometimes we're going over
a specific set of questions
that the interviewer has prepared for you.
And one key part that is often
the case in these interviews
is what I like to call data reasoning
and this means that at
some part in the interview,
the interviewer will show you a chart,
will give you a handout.
If it's a video interview
often will just share
his or her screen to show you some data,
some data visualization,
and of course this is what
you will be faced with.
Quite frequently you will
work with lots of data
in consulting, and the key
question is, how good are you?
How are your effective value
at interpreting this data?
And getting insights out of it.
So let's look into an example.
Let's imagine the interviewer
would show you this exhibit
and the case context is,
that you are asked to
look into opportunities
for this company to grow its revenue
and its profit over the next years.
And now you're looking at this chart
and the interviewer might ask you,
well, what do you see here?
What do you make of this?
Any applications you can draw from this?
And in my humble opinion
in situations like those,
there are three quality levels of answers
that candidates give you.
Let's start with the lowest quality level,
the lowest level of insight.
And this is just restating the facts.
So surely if you look
at a slide like this,
you see lots of facts.
You see for instance in year one,
that product A had net
sales of 100 Euro million
and that 20 million units of product A
were sold in year one
and that the company made a profit
of 20 million in that year.
And some candidates
will tell you just that.
Some candidates will just read out things
that you can clearly read
on your slide anyway,
just tell you what exactly the numbers are
that they see there.
And of course I hope you understand that
this is not the best answer.
This is really stating the obvious,
stating the things that everybody can say
by just reading the slide.
So this is the first level of insight.
Let's get to the second level of insight.
And this is providing a qualified summary.
Let's call it this way.
So people look at the information
and do give you some good insights.
Maybe they're able to conclude that
well product A stayed constant
from year one to year two,
so no changes,
or maybe they were able to conclude
that product B doubled in sales.
So from 150 million in year
one, to 300 million in year two,
or that maybe product
C actually is declining
by apparently more than 15% here
in writing sales year on year.
So this would be a second information.
It's a restatement of facts,
a condensation of the
information that you get
and then restating this as
a little qualified summary
for the interviewer
and surely this is already
much better, right?
Than just reading all the facts
but I would argue there's one thing
that really the most
stellar candidates do,
the most outstanding candidates do
that is beyond just providing a summary.
And this is really
looking into the insights,
into the implications
of what you see here.
Well it might be the case that
this is how the products are
that this is how they developing,
but what does this really mean
for the case question at hand?
What do you really make
out of that, right?
This I think is the main question.
So always think back to
the original case question,
what did the interviewer
ask you to actually look at?
Well the question was,
how can this company
increase revenue and profit
over the next years?
So with this information in mind,
what do you make out of this?
And I think here it's one crucial thing
that you need to understand
that product C seems to be
the most important product
for the company in regards to the revenue,
but also in regards to the profit,
but product C is declining.
Revenues are down, profit are down, right?
And while it is true that
product B is growing,
this does not even over
compensated the loss,
that product C is making.
So this is really a problem
that this company is having.
You really need to investigate
what is going on with product C,
why isn't it performing that well anymore,
because if we don't fix this,
it will be very difficult
for this company.
And this is exactly what
the stellar candidate
would have been able to
draw out, to see this,
to find this implication,
to find this award
and then link it back
to the case question.
Don't just restate some facts.
Don't just summarize things,
but make it clear what the
implications of that are
for the manager, for the CEO,
for your client tomorrow.
Show that you are able to see this.
Next is the quantitative
part of the interview.
So surely in consulting,
we work with data, with numbers a lot,
and it's always great that the interviewer
will look for that.
Whether you are comfortable with numbers,
whether you are good at calculations.
And here my first tip would be,
before you even get a math
question for the interviewer,
try to show whenever it makes sense
that you're really
comfortable with the numbers.
So here staying with this example,
it would have been great
that without even getting a question,
that you would have just
calculated for instance,
the unit price that this
company sells the products to.
So for instance product A,
you can always divide
net sales by units sold,
then hundred over 20 would
mean a unit price of five Euro
or for product B 150 over 60
would be a unit price of 2.5 Euro
or product C 480 over 240
would be a unit price of two Euro, right?
So five, two and a half and two.
And by doing that you could
have then also compared
whether the pricing would have changed
between year one and year two,
because this of course
might've also influenced
how the different numbers
changed year on year
and if you did this,
you would have realized that
the pricing did not change
the price stayed constant over time.
The similar thing that you
could just have calculated,
which would just have been
strong if you just mentioned this
without even anybody asking you for that,
it's just the profit margins
for these different products.
So here for product A,
20 million profit over
a hundred million sales
would be a profit margin of 20%.
Product B with 30 over 150
would also have been a
profit margin of 20%,
but then product C 240 over 480,
here we can see that this is
a profit margin of 50%, right?
So 20, 20 50,
and this would have just stressed
and underlined your point
of saying that this company
really has a significant issue
because product C really
is the most profitable one
not only in absolute numbers,
but also in relative numbers,
providing a profit margin
of 50% for every unit
of this product C that
the company is selling.
Doing calculations like that
with mental math is of course,
very confident, very strong,
shows that you know what you're doing
and really have all the numbers in order.
What interviewers like to do
is then ask you to do some calculations
often also with numbers
provided on a chart exhibit
like this one.
Here you need to know that
usually you're only allowed
to work with pen and paper,
which means that you should
practice written multiplication
written division before you
walk into the interviewer
because even if you are good at math,
of more complex calculations
if you're not practice with doing them
on pen and paper without a calculator,
often you will really
mess up the calculations
and this is surely what you should avoid.
And here also be ready
to do these calculations
up to the first or second
or third decimal point.
Sometimes interviewer just
want to see that you are able
to really get these calculations right
also to the first or second decimal.
Make sure you can do that
because this might be expected from you.
The third area I wanna talk
about is the qualitative part
of the case interview.
Here it will be about structuring
a problem into its issues,
into its drivers, all the
aspects that are relevant.
So in the context of this little
example you have for today,
the interviewer might ask you
to come up with all the relevant
drivers or decision factors
that influence the ability of the company
to really increase its revenue and profit
over the next years.
So this is a typical business-related
structuring question.
And here now the key thing is of course
to have a structure that you use
to not just engage in
a brainstorming mood,
but to show that you are
able in a repeatable way
to create insights like that.
And one big error that many people do
is that they get all these books
with all these case prep frameworks,
and they learn 30, 40, 50,
60 frameworks or so by heart,
believing that just the
more frameworks they know
the better,
and they just need to
learn the perfect framework
for every individual case
that exists out there
just to be fine.
But this of course is quite dangerous
because it's very likely that
the case that you will get
just will not fit any specific
framework that you memorized.
So I would not recommend you to learn
all these frameworks like that,
but I do think it is worthwhile to learn
a handful of frameworks,
which you would be able
to use quite often.
And I think here for
these qualitative purposes
probably the most powerful one
is a business situation type of framework.
So framework that you can use to structure
and analyze different factors
that affect business decisions.
And they wondering the known one
is the so-called three C
framework or the three C model.
So company, customer, competition.
So for instance if you would
now analyze this specific case,
you would first want to learn more
about the company, your client.
So what are the capabilities
of the employees?
How was the organization look like
and what countries are they active?
How does their product
portfolio look like?
What's the pricing looking
like and so on and so forth,
some will in turn affect us.
Second, customers, right?
So what different customer segments exist?
What are their preferences?
Which segments are growing?
Which are declining?
And so on and so forth.
And then third competition.
So what is your market shareholders?
This maybe differ by region.
How does your product
compare to their products?
What are the differentiating
factors USPs that you have
compared to them?
So just a couple of factors
that you can always go over
in these situations.
An adaptation from there that
I always liked really to use
is to use this but then discuss product
in a separate bucket, in a separate area
because the problem that I
feel like a bit of you use
company, customer, competition is this,
that this is just so widely used,
so widely known, that
often the interviewer
will just get a bit bored, right?
If you start with this
just because probably every
second or every third candidate
will have a framework like that.
And for this specific reason,
I do think it also makes sense
that maybe you wanna think
about your own version
of organizing these factors,
just to make it a little
bit more innovative,
just to not make it seem
like the same structure
that you just learned by heart
that everyone else is using.
Last but not least on this point
what's also important
is how you present it.
And here my key advice is to
present in a top-down way,
top-down communication
is what it's all about.
If you have no clue at
all what this means,
I will link another video above here
where I explain this concept in detail,
but specifically for this idea,
here is what you need to do.
Always first start by
presenting the first level,
then the second level,
then the third level
and so on, right?
So when you now present your structure,
start by saying, okay, I
looked into three things.
First, the company, second
customer, third competition.
You explain the structure.
Then you go into the first bucket.
So let's start with the company.
In the company, I have these elements
I'd like to talk about.
Element one, element two,
element three, element four.
So let's go into element one.
This is what this is about.
Element two, this is what this is about.
So always keep the
pyramid principle in mind
there's other concept I'll also talk about
in this other video,
being well structured and well organized
is one of the most important
skills in consulting
and the interviewer will
look for exactly this skill,
specifically here in the question types
where it's about qualitative
structuring of factors.
And last but not least,
I promised you, that in the
end I would share the one tip
which I think really makes
the difference for me
and also for many other people that I know
that successfully prepared
for consulting case interviews
and this key point,
is doing practice cases with other people.
Do practice cases with other people
who also prepare for their
consulting case interviews.
And the key problem that
also I had at the time
is of course, to find other people,
because surely you don't just
wanna do this with everyone,
but with someone who knows really good
and can really help you
and for this reason,
I'm very happy to
introduce you to PrepLounge
a company that I'm partnering with
and that is also sponsoring this video
because PrepLounge is a case
interview preparation platform
that helps candidates to really
prepare for their interviews
to make sure that they can
ace the interview process
of any of these leading consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG or Bain.
I absolutely believe that
the most important aspect
of preparing for case interviews
is really to become comfortable
with solving complex problems
just in the atmosphere
that you will also find in
real case interview situations.
And for me it seems obvious
that this can only be achieved
by practicing cases as much as possible
and receiving feedback
from real case partners.
And this is where
PrepLounge comes into play
because they bring together
aspiring consultants,
management consultants
from around the world
to do just that, just to practice cases.
PrepLounge offers you a vast case library,
interactive content,
personalized training plans
for your preparation
and what's probably best
is that you can match
with other people who are
also currently preparing
for their case interviews and
do mock cases with each other
to improve both of your skills.
In addition to that, you
can also book sessions
with current or former consultants
from for instance, MBB firms
or also other consulting firms
and they will coach you
and rock together with you
to improve your case interview game.
So if you're interested to that,
check out the link to PrepLounge
in the video description,
sign up is completely free,
there is also a premium membership though
if you wanna have access to some
of the advanced
functionalities and features,
but what's great is that
PrepLounge also provided
a discount code to the
Firm Learning community.
So with the code Heinrich15,
you get 15% off on the premium membership.
I will include the link in
the description as well.
So just check this out if
this feels of value to you.
So if you have any other questions
on your case interview preparation,
please leave me a comment
in the comment section.
If you took any value out
of this video darling,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm and subscribe.
My name is Heinrich
I release videos every single Saturday,
big thanks to all the
members of the channel
you're really making a difference.
So see you again next
week, until then, bye bye.